When I was taking the script around and,
and because it's a love story between a mother and a daughter. I remember every,
every man I talked to who was raised with sisters or who had a
daughter said, I know this that's my wife and my daughter,
or that's my sister and my mom and guys who didn't, as they said,
I don't do women fight like this. Like, Oh,
never seen this because why would you know that this is what
this relationship is.
This is Ripley last survivor of the NIS drama
signing off.
The movie.
Alien provides a fascinating case study into how women are typically written in
an early draft of the script.
The screenwriter wrote that the crew's unisex and all parts are interchangeable
for men or women.
The character of Ripley can't really reinforce stereotypes about women because
the writer did not have a woman in mind in the first place. In many ways,
a largely genderless hero is a great character to have in a critically acclaimed
Hollywood blockbuster.
There's something cathartic about not having to think about gender in a main
character.
Writing without a woman in mind means a writer can explore universal human
experiences without worrying about falling into stereotype.
It's definitely fun and exciting to see a character who doesn't get treated
differently because she's a woman.
She is a well-written character with qualities not associated with any
particular gender.
Ripley in alien is a strong woman character because gender plays a very little
role and her strengths could just as easily exist in a masculine character.
Ripley is just one of the many valid ways to approach writing women.
She plays out the fantasy that gender can be ignored,
and that leads to a great movie with a great lead,
but a big strength of film is its ability to tell different human experiences.
And the real world is usually much different than Ripley's.
Your gender plays a huge part in your identity.
There's nothing wrong with a movie that explores a character without exploring
their gender,
but a movie that incorporates gender into the story can lead to moving in
diverse character arts. Good evening. Larry,
maybe the best example of writing women with gender at the forefront is Clarice
Starling. In silence of the lands.
She stands out in the masculine dominated world of the FBI,
and she is rarely taken seriously by her masculine counterparts. Most guys,
either subtly check her out or blatantly hit on her.
Frederick Chilton thinks she was only assigned to interview Lecter because
she's.
I graduated from UVA. Doctorate is not a term school. Good.
Then you should be able to remember the rules.
Perhaps the moments that emphasize her gender the most are the subjective point
of view. Shots of men gazing at her.
They're always looking at either in contempt or attraction,
clearly marking her as an outsider.
And there's more to pointing out her gender than just to show sexism in the
workplace for gender has clearly shaped parts of her character arc.
She personally identifies with the women abducted by Buffalo.
Bill seemed the wake of,
one of the girls gives her a flashback of her father's death.
The opening shot of the movie has Clarice pulling herself up the Hill and her
goal in the movie is to save the captured girls from holes.
They cannot pull themselves out of what did you do?
I went downstairs.
I crept up into the barn. So scared to look inside.
What did you see, Larry? What did you see?
Screaming? You ran away.
Catherine. I'm going to get you out of there right now.
Listen to me,
the climactic finale of the movie is the ultimate visual link between the
Buffalo bill abductions and the men looking down on Clarice in Buffalo bills
layer. He watches over her while she's unable to see him.
Don't you feel eyes moving of your body. Clearly, of course,
this scene is creepy and incredible all on its own,
but it also means more because she is a woman.
And because we have already inhabited her perspective as a woman in a world
where men glare at her and objectify her,
she has a universal journey of triumph against adversity,
but the obstacles in her path are shaped by the fact that she is a woman.
If she were played by a man, the movie would feel drastically different.
Unlike Ripley in alien starlings,
gender elevates the emotional payoff of the movie.
Starlings gender is a key component of her character arc. It's a realistic,
grounded and important story,
but a movie starring a woman doesn't always have to focus on the struggles of
being a woman.
Satisfaction.
The Brighton kill bill is certainly not genderless.
Her story begins when she's shot at her own wedding while pregnant immediately
after waking from a coma, she goes on her quest for revenge on her assailant,
her former lover bill,
the bride embodies the character traits of a traditional masculine hero.
Revenge is a classic staple of drama and a common plot line for narratives.
Typically starring men in contrast alien and silence of the lambs have more in
common with a survival narrative,
Ripley survives and invasion of an alien monster.
Starling does choose to confront the villain herself,
but much of her story involves surviving events that are out of her control.
She has to withstand the gaze of other men,
especially in the climates when she's blind to the villains,
staring right at her with kill bill. The story is completely driven by the hero.
Her journey is not a situation she's thrust into, but rather a conscious plan.
She devised for herself.
This quest for revenge echoes the popular storylines of old American westerns
were heroes decide to reconcile some past trauma like Ripley in alien.
She fulfills a fantasy of transcending her gender,
but instead of being genderless like Ripley,
the bride fulfills the fantasy of being the action hero archetype traditionally
associated with a man. The bride does not act gender neutral.
She acts in a masculine way,
just like the male heroes before her she's aggressive.
She takes charge of the story and she gets her revenge kill.
Bill fulfills the fantasy that a female character can act like a male hero.
The movie gives a fresh perspective on writing women.
She is never a victim in this movie when men wrong her,
she always fights back immediately.
Starling had to tolerate the men in her life,
but the bride doesn't have to like the characters before her she's tapping into
the fantasy of being able to right every wrong.
The trade-off is that this movie does not seem to tap into a distinctly feminine
experience.
What I mean by that is her near death feels like this symbolic death of a
delicate more feminine side of her as appropriate.
And bad-ass as this transformation might be,
there does seem to be a part of the female experience missing in this story.
All three of these movies, right?
Women with some element of a masculine perspective.
Elian is a movie where the characters could have been played by men.
The silence of the lambs has Clarice interacting almost exclusively with men and
kill. Bill has a woman playing a masculine role.
It's also worth noting that all of these movies were written and directed by
men. So it makes sense that there are some masculine elements in each of them.
Maybe the last piece of the puzzle is a movie that embraces an experience
exclusive to women, right?
You're not even worth state tuition, Christine. My name is lady bird. Oh,
well actually it's not. And it's ridiculous.
Most coming of age movies,
Christine's romantic interest in Ladybird are fleeting and unimportant.
She paints over her crushes names before moving out a visual reminder that she
has completely moved on and those relationships do not have a permanent effect
on her. The relationship with her mother is explored with much more detail.
The opening shot instantly shows us the movie's emotional core in the script.
Greta Gerwig describes this opening shot as a modern day,
romantic Mary Kasam rip-off painting of motherhood.
Mary Cassat was an impressionist painter known for her images of women in social
and private life. Unlike many painters at that time,
Casani consistently portrayed her women with a dignity that suggested deeper,
more intimate views of her characters.
People look at COSATU paintings and relate to the mother child interactions in
their familiar activities.
The thoughtful expressions of many of her subjects gives them a certain
intellectual look like there's more than meets the eye.
I think Greta Gerwig wants to capture that exact spirit in this movie.
Ladybird gives an incredible look at the complicated relationship between two
women who would have thought a mother's opinion on the clothes her daughter
tries on could have so many layers.
We want you to be the very best version of yourself. That you're
what if this is the best version.
This scene ends with the mom,
trying to think of what to say and cutting to the next scene before she's able
to Gerwig noted that lady bird and her mother are most intimate when they are
unconscious. In the first frame,
we will never see them be this close to each other for the rest of the film.
Ironically, they also look extremely similar,
which Gerwig reinforces in the match cuts of them driving despite their
similarities.
These characters try to be as different from each other as possible.
It's this complicated back and forth relationship that makes their scenes so
full of death.
You are so infuriated, stop yelling, not yelling, Oh,
I love it.
The characters are imperfect.
And most importantly vulnerable while there's value in the female bad-ass is
like kill bill.
There's also a strength in embracing the weaknesses and faults a person can
have.
It's about covering the entire spectrum of human experience where a female can
act masculine in one movie and feminine in another women,
directors and writers can give an honest and relatable depiction of women
experiences. In addition to the fantasies of FBI agents, space, explorers,
and assassins,
and it's important that all these kinds of characters exist for women.
Each of these characters gives us a different look into the human experience.
Maybe a well-written character played by a woman,
challenges you to think a little differently.
Maybe they challenge you to look without gender or to see women from a new
perspective. If it works, it works.
There's no wrong way to write women at the end of the day.
The great part about cinema is how it gives us a window into worlds.
We wouldn't have seen on our own combine that with the connectivity of the
internet and the possibilities are endless.
If you're looking to expand your understanding across many different subjects,
then I highly recommend the award-winning documentaries. On curiosity stream.
Curiosity stream is a subscription streaming service founded by John Hendricks,
the founder of the discovery channel.
It offers over 2000 documentaries and non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers.
They have a great series on Viking women that goes in depth on the experience of
women in the masculine culture. They lived in go to curiosity, stream.com/.
Now you see it for unlimited access to the world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series under the promo code. Now you see a,
when prompted during the signup process and your membership is completely free
for the first time.
[Inaudible].